la parole est à notre collègue jean paul
fournier pour le groupe l'est
républicain
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues ma question s'adresse au
ministre de l'intérieur
nous assistons en france à une
recrudescence de vandalisme envers les
lieux de culte des lieux de culte
musulmans lieux de culte juifs de culte
chrétiens également ce sont les plus
nombreux et mon département du gard n'y
a pas fait exception
chaque jour en effet deux lieux de culte
chrétiens sont profanées en france et l'
incendie de l'église de fontainebleau ce
week-end est venu allonger une liste
déjà trop longue
comme beaucoup de français je vais
inquiète cette multiplication d'actes
anti chrétiens dont les statistiques
émanant de vos propres services ne cache
plus l'ampleur si seat interpelle à ce
point les français c'est qu'ils ne sont
pas seulement des attaques inadmissibles
contre les croyants c'est aussi et
surtout parce qu ils sont d atteinte
directe à notre culture à notre héritage
cet héritage qui nous oblige tous
aujourd'hui de que nous prenions de
quelques familles politiques que nous
réclamions oui ces actes ne sont pas des
actes de vandalisme comme tant d'autres
ils doivent être regardées comme une
atteinte à la cohésion nationale une
offense à notre république en ce qu'il
touche à ce qui fait notre identité
il appelle donc des condamnations
extrêmement fermé des plus immédiate des
sanctions exemplaires temps pour punir
le préjudice patrimonial inestimable de
cause ces auteurs si ce n'est que pour
rappeler à chacun que le respect la
protection des lieux de culte est un
préalable indispensable pour garantir la
laïcité de notre république
je m'étonne ainsi qu'une une certaine
discrétion qui est faite parfois pour
condamner sans attendre de tels actes or
ce qui est ressenti par la plupart des
français comme une approche sélective
défi grave fracture profonde dans les
communautés religieuses et de facto la
communauté nationale
il fait le lit d'une exaspération qui
n'a que trop duré nous étudions de la
fermeté à l'égard de ces actes qui
touchent à une part capitale
nourrissions et
monsieur le ministre que comptez vous
faire pour endiguer ce phénomène et d'y
donner la priorité qu'il exige pour
répondre la parole et au ministre en
charge des relations avec le parlement
jean marie le guen
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
sénateur jean-paul fournier oui les
incendies dont ont fait l'objet
notamment l'église saint-louis à
fontainebleau et l'église devenaient des
sablons on constitue un véritable
traumatisme évidemment d'abord pour la
communauté des croyants et des fidèles
de cette région mais plus largement chez
nos compatriotes
heureusement il n'ya pas eu à travers
ces profanations de blessure de
personnes les services d'urgence sont
intervenus très rapidement mais il ya eu
un patrimoine très important qui a été
détruit ou peut-être même volé c'est
pourquoi d'ailleurs le ministre de
l'intérieur s'est rendu personnellement
sur place pour rencontrer le maire et
tout les représentants de la communauté
nous avons la conviction que les
enquêtes permettront d'établir les
circonstances précises de ces sinistrés
des auteurs de tels actes doivent savoir
qu'ils seront recherchés et traduits en
justice mais cette affaire vous avez
raison de le souligner elle intervient
dans un contexte beaucoup plus général
et continue d'atteinte au lieu de culte
et aux sépultures
c'est ainsi que 524 églises ont suivi
une atteinte
un nombre en augmentation de 22% par
rapport à la même période de l'année
précédente et une majeure partie de ces
atteintes sont d'origine crapuleuse
néanmoins la plus grande vigilance doit
être de mise
de la même façon que 122 mosquée et 25
synagogues ont été attaqués d'une façon
ou d'une autre dans notre pays nous
avons en mémoire évidemment ce qui s'est
passé à la mosquée dauchot à celle
d'ajaccio et bien évidemment
le cimetière juif de sarre union c'est
pour lutter contre cette situation que
le gouvernement a décidé de renforcer la
protection dont bénéficieront les lieux
de culte 4307 lieux de culte photo jean
flux rejet d'une protection dont des
églises les temples et mosquées les
synagogues 27 millions d'euros ont été
mis en oeuvre par le gouvernement pour
améliorer la protection de ses sites ne
vous l'avez raison de dire monsieur le
sénateur que la laïcité c'est aussi la
défense évidemment de ces lieux de culte
et nous devons être d'une vigilance
totale et d'un engagement total sur ces
sujets